so this this is chromie
he lives inside your computer that is if
you use chrome
oh the ramburger he's everyone's
favorite
or at least most used web browser he's
just got one
tiny problem he can't stop eating your
computer's ram
and other resources have no idea what
i'm talking about
actually i bet you do you know when your
mac or pc's chrome web browser gets slow
and then the entire machine sounds like
it's going to do well
this and liftoff
yes that could be happening because this
guy's eating your computer's resources
for breakfast lunch and dinner
but don't worry you can put them on a
diet and take back your computer with
some of these tips
tip number one just stop using chrome
sure chrome has far more browser market
share than the rest of these guys
but all of them have actually gotten
quite good over the last number of years
heck the new microsoft edge browser even
uses chromium
the same underlying technology as chrome
and the performance is much improved
across windows pcs and macs yes
microsoft's browser is available for
your mac
and it's good in my weeks of testing
edge used five percent less resources
than chrome on windows
safari used up to ten percent less than
some of my tests on my mac
that meant up to two extra hours of
battery life in their respective
operating systems
firefox unfortunately took up just as
much power as chrome
google says it's working on some
resource saving improvements that will
come in the next few months
if you can switch to just one of those
go for it
even if just for their better privacy
tools oh whatever you'll be back
but if you can't switch because chrome
just handles certain websites better or
google apps better
then you need to try one of these next
tips tip number two
spot and kill the ram gobblers first
a little computer 101. every app on your
computer runs a number of tasks in your
system's ram
the more ram you have the more programs
you can run swiftly and simultaneously
every chrome tab and chrome extension is
a different ram
process basically a different app the
bad news of this design is that each
site can be duplicating some back end
work that another is doing
and sites have gotten far more powerful
the good news is that the chrome
task manager lets you see the resources
each tab is using
and close ones that are problematic
click the three vertical dots here
then go to more tools then task manager
and knock out any of the major hogs
tip number three uninstall extensions
this one made the biggest difference on
my laptop
extensions you may have once installed
but barely use
like this cisco webex in my case can run
in the background
and secretly chew on your ram and cpu
you can see this in the same activity
monitor to disable them
go to settings and extensions
oh don't take my extensions now come on
tip number four limit browser-based
video chats
you know what tabs take up the most ram
in cpu power
the ones handling video calls video
calling is a lot more processor
intensive especially when you have
multiple callers
google me used up a whopping 1.5
gigabytes during tests
no matter what the browser heck google
even offers all these google meat tips
for overheating laptops
including one that says using the
spotlight view which shows one caller at
a time will conserve cpu power
another good tip i've picked up to stop
the crazy fan noise
is disconnecting my external monitor
when using a website for video calling
sure if you follow these tips chromie
here is probably gonna be a little bit
more hungry
but your computer it should be quieter
faster
and cooler ah come on just one more bite
i'll tell you which tab the music's
playing from
you